je mène les deux en même temps c'est à
dire que pendant l'entracte pendant
l'entracte et bien je vais passer des
coups de téléphone à mes clients et
aussitôt le spectacle fini je me
démaquille en vitesse je prends mon
attaché case je saute dans ma voiture et
je vais voir mes clients
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non non mais je comprends bien madame
Legrand mais s'il s'agit de vraiment de
d'une signalisation de porte et que
c'est pas son département vert des
porteurs libération là moi je vous
conseille de mettre les plaques que je
vous avais proposé le modèle
bleu bleu si vous voulez on peut les
faire toutes bleues
non non la couleur se change rien sans
rien
d'accord
oui oui au revoir
[Musique]
et à bientôt sur ça
on est pas tout seul
partenaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc la vie de professionnels de
représentants
représentants de commerce et qui est
complètement mêlé à la vie de directeur
de cirque et de clown et je fais les
deux je mène les deux en même temps
c'est à dire que pendant l'entracte
pendant l'entracte et bien je vais
passer d'écoute téléphone à mes clients
et aussitôt le spectacle fini je me
démaquille en vitesse je prends mon
attaché case je saute dans ma voiture et
je vais voir mes clients
très heureux moi je suis venu au cirque
par amour et en plus de ça et bien bon
ben ça fait des dizaines d'années que je
fais du cirque et je peux en profiter
[Musique]
20 ans déjà je suis je travaille comment
je suis et j'ai toujours un trac
toujours
les enfants
c'est pas évident
[Musique]
alors moi je te laisse
un personnage qui fait rêver c'est
l'attrapéziste bien sûr bien sûr
toujours plein de grâce aériennes
prenant des risques aussi une femme qui
prend des risques ça dure quelque chose
du jour souriante et puis c'est aérien
c'est on envoie envie de l'attraper au
vol de la saisir dans ces différentes
pauses on devient amoureux de la
trapéziste non je m'appelle vanille
parce que quand j'ai commencé le trapèze
il est un peu près 7 ans je me parfume à
la vanille j'en mettais partout et puis
on m'a appelé comme ça et c'est resté
[Musique]
lorsqu'on est en piste
il y a d'abord beaucoup d'émotions
surtout si on entend avant les enfants
qui crient parce qu'ils voient le
trapèze descendre ou
un petit peu de peur aussi surtout quand
on commence à se balancer tant que tant
que le trapèze est fixe ça va mais au
moment on commence à prendre de l'élan
où il y a un risque plus important il y
a encore un peu plus d'émotions
c'est aussi 5 6 minutes un petit peu
hors du temps
on pense à rien d'autre on fait ce qu'on
a à faire on fait le numéro mais
le reste le reste s'arrête
c'est vrai que je sens aussi quand le
public a peur l'écrit les
[Musique]
ma vie ici si je peux dire c'est une
partie de d'un rêve pour moi ça fait
longtemps que je voulais ne faire que du
cirque que du trapèze et
c'est arrivé cette année donc pour moi
c'est important
c'est un peu de magie un peu de les
paillettes bon même si dans la réalité
il y a aussi des choses plus dures quoi
plus pas évidentes mais c'est quand même
un rêve
[Musique]
je suis venu ici la première fois pour
passer l'audition
j'ai craqué quoi quand j'ai vu ce petit
cirque avec des
plein plein de vieilles choses
du début du siècle ou les couleurs le
rouge le bleu le jaune
l'espace qui est pas très grand côté
intimité chaleureux
qu'elle a plus beaucoup comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas trop c'est un clown alors ça va
parce qu'il est il est à la fois clown
sur piste et clown dans la vie alors je
crois que ça ça rend les choses quand
même beaucoup plus agréable et ce qui
est très bien aussi avec lui je pense
c'est qu'il a il est toujours en train
de d'inventer de de d'être à l'écoute
des idées nouvelles et de toujours
vouloir un peu foncer en avant et ça
c'est agréable quand on est jeune je
crois parce que c'est si nous on a envie
justement de foncer il est prêt à nous
suivre et je crois qu'on est prêt à le
suivre une jeune artiste m'avait dit je
connais un jeune garçon vladique c'est
son nom d'artiste bien sûr et qui fait
du fil de fer et je lui ai téléphoné il
m'a dit moi du fil de fer je veux bien
en faire mais mais mes croisières et mon
câble sont sous mon lit et je n'ai pas
l'occasion de pouvoir le faire parce
qu'il a une formation de danseur sur
tout ça je lui dis mais venez venez
monter votre matériel aussi et venez
répéter quand vous voulez
le cirque il est à vous en dehors des
spectacles et vous venez et c'est ce
qu'il a fait et donc il est venu pendant
plusieurs années répété s'entraîner sous
le chapiteau et il est excellent dans ce
dans cette discipline et dans son rôle
[Musique]
deux artistes qui se sont sauvés du
cirque de canton quand il est passé en
France et qui sont là chez nous qui vont
vraiment un numéro de numéro
exceptionnel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est fini
droite
un beau sourire à Madame
un gros baisers aussi voilà on avait
prête sur ton couleur s'il vous plaît
allez
[Musique]